WASN’T, WE’RE GOING TO START
FROM ZERO IN THE HOUSE SO LET’S
BRING IN HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN MCCARTHY.
I THOUGHT YOU GUYS WERE GOING TO
TAKE THE SENATE BILL AND
BASICALLY MAKE MINOR CHANGES AND
JUST STAMP IT, BUT IS NANCY
PELOSI GOING TO START FROM
SCRATCH?
>> NO SHE’S NOT SHE’S PLAYING
POLITICAL GAMES AND SHE NEVER
SHOULD HAVE SAID THAT.
THERE IS NOBODY IN THE HOUSE
HERE BUT NANCY, I, AND MYSELF.
SHE CAN NOT CRAFT ANOTHER BILL.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
PEOPLE WILL LOSE THEIR JOB TODAY
BECAUSE OF WHAT SCHUMER AND THE
OTHERS ARE PORTRAYING AND
DOING.
WE ARE CLOSER THAN WE HAD BEEN.
I WAS IN THE MEETING YESTERDAY
WITH THE FOUR LEADERS.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT PROCESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL
DID?
HE DID FROM THE BOTTOM UP.
HE HAD DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICAN
SENATORS TOGETHER ACTUALLY
WORKING OUT THE BILL.
IT WAS THE LEADERS WHO CAME IN
AND STOPPED THIS PROCESS.
AND WHAT SENATOR SCHUMER’S
COMPLAINING ABOUT IS RESOURCES
PROVIDED TO COMPANIES TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES HIRED.
TO ME THIS IS THE LOWEST LEVEL.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE OF WHAT
WE JUST SAW A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
IN THE HOUSE, WHEN WE DIDN’T GET
TO WORK WITH NANCY PELOSI,
OUR OWN MEMBERS HAD CRAFTED A
BILL BUT WHEN WE FINALLY GOT THE
BILL WE’RE ABLE TO MAKE THE
CHANGES TO IT EVEN THE
LANGUAGE WAS NOT CORRECT
LATE INTO THE NIGHT, BUT I MOVED
THE BILL FORWARD BECAUSE I
WANTED AMERICA TO SEE US WORKING
TOGETHER, TO GIVE US HOPE THAT
WE CAN DO THIS AND ON A
HANDSHAKE, WE SAID WE WOULD FIX
THAT BILL ON MONDAY, THE
TECHNICAL CHANGES.
WHAT THE SENATORS DID LAST NIGHT
, IT WASN’T EVEN VOTE ON
THE BILL.
THEY HAD 30 MORE HOURS, THEY
WERE SIMPLY MOVING THE PROCESS
FORWARD, TO GIVE THIS COUNTRY
HOPE TO SHOW THAT THEY CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
THIS IS UNCALLED FOR.
THIS IS GOING TO DO DAMAGE TO US
, AND IT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THE COUNTRY DOES NOT WANT US TO
BE PARTISAN.
THEY WANT US TO BE PRODUCTIVE
AND THAT IS WHAT WE DID IN THE
MINORITY OVER ON THIS SIDE
AND WHAT WE EXPECT TO HAPPEN
THERE BUT THEY HAD MORE INPUT
THAN ANY OTHER TIME.
I WISH WE HAD THAT TYPE OF INPUT
WHEN WE WOULD CRAFT A BILL.
STEVE: I TELL YOU WHAT LEADER
MCCARTHY, NEWT GINGRICH WHO ONCE
UPON A TIME WAS SPEAKER, HE
MENTIONED YOU, AND TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW TO THE REPUBLICANS VIA
THE DEMOCRATS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE NOW IS A POWER
STRUGGLE WHERE PELOSI AND
SCHUMER BELIEVE THEY CAN
BLACKMAIL THE PRESIDENT INTO
ACCEPTING A REALLY DUMB IDEA AND
AGAIN, I THINK THERE’S SOME
THINGS YOU NEGOTIATE AND
SOME THINGS YOU CAN WORK OUT BUT
I PERSONALLY DO NOT WANT TO SEE
A TRUMP MCCONNELL MCCARTHY
TEAM THAT ARE BLACKMAILED BY
PELOSI AND SCHUMER AND GET IN.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND WE CAN GET
SOMETHING DONE IMMEDIATELY
THIS WEEK, THE HOUSE HAS TO COME
BACK TO DO IT BUT THEY
OUGHT TO PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON PELOSI AND SCHUMER TO PUT
AMERICA AT A PARTISANSHIP.
STEVE: SO LEADER MCCARTHY IS
THAT WHAT’S GOING ON ARE THEY
BLACKMAILING YOUR SIDE?
>> THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO ASK FOR.
THE THINGS THAT THEY ARE ASKING
FOR , THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
ELECTION LAW.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT MONEY
THAT WAS GOING TO PLACES, THINK
FOR ONE MOMENT WHAT WE WERE ABLE
TO DO BEFORE.
WE’VE SENT MORE MONEY TO THE
STATE.
WE INCREASED THE FUNDING LEVEL
THERE THAT WE FOUND TIME TO WORK
TOGETHER.
THIS IS ACTUALLY TO PROTECT THE
JOBS TO PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES FOR WHAT WE NEED IN
DEALING WITH THIS SITUATION.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE BUT
WHAT’S SO CRITICAL HERE IS THE
ACTUAL SENATORS, DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS GOT TOGETHER AND
CRAFTED THE BILL.
IT IS THE LEADERSHIP THAT HAS
COME IN, BECAUSE THEY ARE
UNHAPPY THAT THEY COULDN’T CRAFT
IT THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THE WAY OUR FOUNDERS
BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE WRITTEN
THE BILL AND FOR THEM TO HOLDUP
ANY PROCESS OF MOVING FORWARD IS
NOT EVEN VOTING ON THE BILL.
IT’S GIVING THE 30 HOURS OF
DEBATE TO START MOVING.
CHUCK SCHUMER SHOULD ALLOW THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD AND THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
AINSLEY: NANCY PELOSI SAYS THE
HOUSE WILL INTRODUCE ITS OWN
BILL.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID.
>> THEY ARE SO FAR APART SHOULD
PEOPLE BE CONCERNED THIS WON’T
PASS BY MONDAY?
>> WE’RE STILL TALKING.
IT’S ON THE SENATE SIDE NOW,
BECAUSE THAT’S THEIR DEADLINE
FOR A VOTE, BUT WE’LL BE
INTRODUCING OUR OWN BILL AND
HOPEFULLY IT’LL BE COMPATIBLE
WITH WHAT THEY DISCUSS IN THE
SENATE.
>> SO NO DEAL THE BIPARTISAN AT
THIS POINT?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT NEWT
GINGRICH WAS TALKING ABOUT.
SHE HAS NO BILL, SHE HAS NO
PEOPLE AND SHE HAS NO MEMBERS.
THAT WAS A POLITICAL PLOY TO
GIVE COVER TO SCHUMER TO GET HIS
DEMOCRATS TO VOTE NO.
THIS IS A MOMENT IN TIME THAT
THOSE DEMOCRAT SENATORS SHOULD
NOT SIT BACK AND TAKE THE
DIRECTION OF LEADERSHIP.
PUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC FIRST.
BRIAN:  BUT KEVIN HERE IS WHAT
THEY SAY SPECIFICALLY.
YOU’RE DOING A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS, GIVING MONEY TO SMALL
BUSINESSES SAYING IF YOU USE
THIS MONEY, TO KEEP YOUR
EMPLOYEES PAID, YOU CAN TAKE
THIS AS A GRANT.
IF YOU FIRE YOUR EMPLOYEES IT IS
A LOAN AND THEN YOU SAID FOR TWO
YEARS, I DON’T WANT THESE
CORPORATIONS BUYING THEIR STOCK
BACK.
THE DEMOCRATS SAID I WANT IT
LONGER THAN TWO YEARS, SO AND
THEY ALSO WANT MORE MONEY TO
HOSPITALS AND MORE MONEY TO
STATES.
I MEAN, IS THERE SOMETHING IS
THERE A GREY AREA YOU GUYS CAN
DIVE INTO THERE?
WHAT IS THE MAIN OBJECTION FROM
WHAT I JUST SAID?
>> WELL LISTEN, WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE YOU HAVE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS IS LIQUIDITY.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE ASK AS A GOVERNMENT
THAT YOU HAD TO SHUT DOWN TO
HELP OUR HEALTH.
WE SHOULD ALLOW THOSE PEOPLE TO
HELP THEM DURING THIS BRIDGE GAP
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WANT
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE WORKING.
WE INCREASE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE HERE IF SOMEONE GETS
LAID OFF BUT WHAT WE’RE REALLY
DOING IS HELPING THE SMALL
BUSINESS STAY AFLOAT, PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND PAY THEIR RENT.
WE’RE DOING THE SAME THING ON
EVERY BUSINESS AS WE GO FORWARD.
THAT IS WHAT YOU NEED.
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO STAY WORKING.
AND FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO HOLD
THIS UP, WE’RE PROVIDING MORE
MONEY TO THE STATES WE’RE
PROVIDING MORE MONEY TO
HEALTHCARE, WE’RE MOVING THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO GET
DONE BUT THEY’RE HOLDING IT
UP WHILE THEY COULD STILL
NEGOTIATE FOR THE NEXT 30 HOURS.
THEY ARE VERY FEW THINGS THAT
DIVIDE THEM ON THIS BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WROTE
THIS BILL TOGETHER.
WHAT IS HOLDING THEM UP IS THE
ATTITUDE OF LEADERSHIP THAT
SOMEHOW THEY ARE NOT GETTING
CREDIT FOR?
THIS IS A MOMENT IN TIME THAT
YOU SHOULD STEP BACK AND PUT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC FIRST BEFORE
YOU WANT YOUR OWN LITTLE TITLE
ON IT.
STEVE: LEADER MCCARTHY ON THE
SENATE SIDE FIVE REPUBLICANS
ARE OUT BECAUSE THEY ARE IN SELF
-QUARANTINE AND RAND PAUL
TESTED POSITIVE.
GOING FORWARD, IS THE HOUSE
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO REMOTELY
VOTE OR  HOW WILL GOVERNMENT RUN
IF PEOPLE ARE SICK?
>> LOOK, WE WILL FIGURE THAT
OUT.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS
TALKING TO THE SPEAKER ABOUT
THAT, WAYS THAT WE CAN GET THIS
VOTE FORWARD BUT THAT
EVEN POINTS TO BIGGER PROBLEM
RIGHT HERE.
WHY WOULD THE DEMOCRATS HOLD IT
UP IN A HOPE ENTER OF TIME THAT
MORE PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK?
THE CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT YOU
WANT TO KEEP TOGETHER AND WE
WILL BUT WHAT’S MORE IMPORTANT,
THE MILLIONS OF AMERICANS OUT
THERE THAT NEED OUR HELP TODAY
PUT YOUR OWN AMBITIONS ASIDE AND
PUT AMERICA FIRST.
LET’S SOLVE THIS PROBLEM, LET’S
MOVE THE SYSTEM FORWARD AND
ALLOW THE DEBATE TO CONTINUE, TO
SIT BACK AND SAY NO, OR  PUT
THIS BELIEF THAT THE HOUSE IS
GOING TO START CRAFTING THAT BE
TOO LATE AND TOO LITTLE AND
WE WOULD LOOK BACK IN HISTORY AT
THIS MOMENT IN TIME AND LOOK AT
THE DAMAGE THAT WAS CREATED JUST
BECAUSE OF A PERSONALITY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WANTED SOME TYPE
OF CREDIT OR  TO LEVERAGE
SOMETHING A LITTLE FURTHER.
THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR
PARTISANSHIP.
THIS IS A TIME FOR US TO BE
PRODUCTIVE.
JUST AS WE SHOWED REPUBLICANS
INSIDE THIS HOUSE THAT WE VOTED
ON A BILL THAT DID NOT HAVE THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE AGREED TO,
BECAUSE WE PUT THIS COUNTRY
FIRST, BECAUSE WE DID IT ON A
HANDSHAKE THAT WE WOULD SOLVE IT
LATER AND IT WAS.
THAT IS NOT HAPPENING IN THE
SENATE, WHILE THEY HAD MORE
INPUT THAN WE’VE EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
AINSLEY: LEADER MCCARTHY THANK